well thanks very much for for your
question and you're posting but I don't
agree we've got to make sure that growth
and the environment are not alternatives
but they go together we need green
growth so I don't think there is some
set level of growth that if you exceed
your necessarily going to damage the
environment we're going to make sure
that growth can go along with perfecting
our environment how do we do that we for
instance we've got to make sure that
when it comes to electricity generation
and distribution and use we have a smart
grid that people can interact with that
you can produce your own electricity's
and sell the surplus back to the grid
you can plug in electric cars you can
make possible the renewable energies
that can be need to be used in bulk such
as tidal wind wave and solar power so
these things must have built an ax to
the road of politicians is we've got to
work out how you make growth and
greenery go together and I think it's
particularly important that in a
recession that we don't junk our
commitment to the environment and to
tackling climate change i think is
tempting for politicians they know of
course the priority must be everything
to do with the recession let's forget
about the environment that would be a
mistake we've got to make sure we do
things now that help people to get out
of the recession to get jobs and that
help businesses but are also good for
the environment in the future and
investing in green technology and green
businesses and green ideas for the
future is one that we work very well